buckle up beehive because beyonce's
talking fame
and new music in a new rare interview
i'm very happy queen bee graces the
cover of harper's bazaar's september
icons issue
and inside the mag she opens up about
her personal approach to being an
international
superstar quote before i started i
decided that i'd only pursue this career
if my self-worth was dependent on more
than celebrity success
beyonce says she surrounded herself with
honest people who she admires
who have their own lives and dreams and
are not dependent on her
in this business so much of your life
does not belong to you unless you fight
for it
i fought to protect my sanity and my
privacy because
the quality of my life depended on it a
lot of who i am
is reserved for the people i love and
trust
this makes me proud the grammy winner
also teases that
new music is in the works saying she's
been in the studio for a
year and a half with all the isolation
and injustice over the past year i think
we are all ready to escape
travel love and laugh again i feel a
renaissance emerging and i want to be
part of nurturing that
escape in any way possible adding quote
yes the music is coming are you making
some musical soup right i'm thinking i'm
cooking some music
back in may beyonce revealed she was
back in the studio during a group
chat with her destiny's child bandmates
michelle williams and
kelly rowland that's chef boyardee and
chef
kelly michelle shared the sweet convo on
her instagram
alongside the caption quote everybody's
in the kitchen
so what kind of music is bee cooking on
monday the 39 year old singer's mom
tina knowles lawson hit up instagram
saying she'd like to see her daughter do
more gospel and country music
which is interesting since beyonce rocks
a black cowboy hat
and lots of fringe on the cover of
harper's and just last week
beyonce released this campaign video for
her latest streetwear collection named
ivy park rodeo that's the houston native
rocking the ivy park by adidas designs
including a denim bodysuit denim chaps
and a cow print sports bra
and leggings set along with some dolly
parton s
curls and a floor length braid which she
swings above her head like a lasso
okay so we might have to wait to see if
country music is what beyonce has
cooking
but this new ivy park ad has us saying
howdy y'all
[Music]